merci president thank you president
sasoli today we celebrate 10
000 stories of ingenuity hard work
and endurance we celebrate people who
have
pushed the boundaries of human knowledge
a bit further
and we celebrate the institution that
put trust in them
giving them the possibility to try to
innovate to discover
something new this is why
the european research council was
created 14 years ago
to give european scientists the freedom
to explore the frontiers of knowledge
this is the foundation of human progress
everyone knows the story of newton's
apple
but after he saw an apple falling from a
tree
it took newton over 10 years to first
publish his theory so science takes
time dedication and yes
it needs resources
let me borrow the words of professor ur
shaheen
i believe you all know his name he is
the founder of biontech
who together with his wife wife islam
turetchi
developed the first mrna vaccine against
kavit
and he too is a grantee
of the european research council
professor shaheen recently said and i
quote
the success of an idea is really based
on a single discovery
but on long-term persistence and
financial support
of early pioneers believing in a vision
end of quote this is the mission of the
european research council
it provides researchers with the time
the trust and the resources they need
so they can turn their intuitions into
scientific breakthroughs
and for this reason two-thirds of erc
grants
have been awarded to early-stage
researchers
45 000 phd students and postdocs
worked on projects financed by the
european research council
it's a new generation of scientists and
it is made in europe
and at the same time support from the
european research council
has led to ground breaking discoveries
the list of achievements by erc grantees
is simply
stunning seven nobel prizes
the first real image of a black hole
the concept of planetary boundaries
which is crucial to our understanding of
climate change
and i could continue this kind of
innovation
will be even more necessary in the years
ahead
we need the help of science to address
the great
challenges of our times from climate
change
to mastering the digital age to fighting
pandemics
thus i am proud that the new european
budget includes
16 billion euros for the european
research council
this is unprecedented and we had to
fight for it
but these resources can make a huge
difference
for european researchers
today we announce the ten thousands
grant
from erc it took 14 years to get there
now with the new funding we could
finance another
10 000 grand already in the next seven
years
so we are going twice as fast as in the
past
europe believes in science and we
believe in our researchers
so congratulations to the 10 000
grantee and to the european research
council for 10
000 stories of scientific excellence
and many more to come many thanks
and congratulations again